john bolton and michael cohen both
speculated
that donald trump likely moved at least
some of the documents the fbi wanted to
a different golf club
and it is now increasingly looking like
that may well be the case
did trump transfer documents to
bedminster that's another one of his
golf clubs ex-fbi official floats the
theory peter strzok
um
had a very interesting tweet thread
uh over the weekend where he said better
check bedminster
on may 6 nara emails trump to say
material is missing and maybe at
mar-a-lago that we know this is part of
what ultimately led to the raid
on may 9th trump gets on a private plane
from paul beach to met bedminster on
video several boxes are seen loaded onto
the plane that is indeed true you see in
this picture there are boxes being
loaded onto the plane okay but we don't
boxes or boxes there could be you know
just sudafed in there could be anything
peter strut goes on to say does the type
and brand of box look familiar
uh well yeah i mean it does look like
the exact type of box that is pictured
in the image of donald trump's office
where the documents were found
great visual says peter strzok though
number one might be two stacked boxes
meaning nine not eight boxes good
example of harm to national security
from waiting to use mar-a-lago
classified documents id and interview
these folks compare their fingerprints
to those on the seas documents and empty
folders
and uh certainly when you look at this
video
you do see
a lot of boxes that look identical to
the ones that were carried out that were
photographed in trump's office being
carried onto the plane that is
absolutely true now it is speculative
this is a speculative case
but it makes perfect sense and remember
trump's own former national security
adviser michael uh michael bull
it would be like trump to have michael
bolton as is uh i make what happened
there is
michael cohen and john bolton i it's a
portmento michael bolton the singer um
john bolton trump's former national
security adviser said he probably moved
documents elsewhere
michael cohen who knows trump well said
he probably has documents elsewhere
these are likely not all the documents
then we find empty folders marked top
secret
and of course trump didn't take empty
folders at some point they had something
in them and where the documents are
remains a question
we don't know for sure but as we build
up a picture of what took place we see
that the likeliest scenario the simplest
explanation
is that there are documents elsewhere
somewhere and now it's a matter of
finding them we'll have the clip i
played of the boxes being loaded if
you're just listening today we'll have
that clip on our instagram find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow if you want
to take a look for yourself
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chilisleep makes customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions that
improve your sleep by keeping you cool
at night chili sleeps cube and uhler
sleep systems are hydro powered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115 i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
it's fantastic and chili sleep is the
only company on the market doing it like
this you'll get thirty percent off your
new cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com pacman the link is down
below